nous sommes un grand pays on a un grand
modèle énergétique nous allons tenir cet
hiver malgré la guerre il y aura-t-il
assez d'électricité pour passer l'hiver
en France c'est l'une des questions qui
revient le plus cette année d'un côté le
gouvernement se montre plutôt rassurant
mais de l'autre les spécialistes sont
inquiets d'où vient ce problème qui est
réellement responsable de cette pénurie
d'électricité réponse dans facture
[Applaudissements]
en France l'énergie nucléaire couvre 71%
des besoins en électricité or la plupart
des centrales sont aujourd'hui vieilles
et abîmées le parc nucléaire français
tourne au ralenti sur les 56 réacteurs
15 sont toujours à l'arrêt
cette année les retards dans le
redémarrage de plusieurs centrales on
comptera la France à acheter de
l'électricité à ses voisins
le nombre de jours importateurs ou le
pays fait venir plus de courant qu'il en
vend à l'étranger a exploser il est
passé de 17 en 2018 à 220 en 2022 c'est
un problème énorme pour la résilience de
notre pays et pour sa capacité à
conduire la transition climatique étant
entendue que comme on importe de
l'électricité de Belgique mais surtout
d’allemagne du coup en importe plus
d'émissions de carbone puisque
l'électricité nucléaire française était
décarbonée l'électricité allemande est
produite à un tiers à partir de charbon
ou de limite ce manque d'électricité est
en réalité la conséquence de plusieurs
facteurs différents celui qui vient le
plus rapidement à l'esprit c'est le
conflit en Ukraine avec des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en énergie mais cela
dit cette explication n'est pas la
principale
si la France est en difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est parce que depuis
maintenant plusieurs dizaines d'années
elle a méthodiquement renoncer à ce qui
faisait sa souveraineté énergétique
et c'était évidemment basé sur le
nucléaire c'était l'une des promesses de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017
réduire la part du nucléaire de 75 à 50%
et d'autres avant lui avait fait cette
promesse au départ pour des raisons
idéologiques c'est Lionel Jospin qui
avait commencé quand il était premier
ministre en 1997 à abandonner cette
filière d'énergie nucléaire civile tout
simplement pour faire plaisir aux
écologistes pour des accords
électoralistes même chose en Allemagne
Angela Merkel a mis fin au nucléaire
après la catastrophe de Fukushima en
alors qui est responsable pour l'État
cedf et pour EDF c'est l'état Emmanuel
Macron a changé d'avis il a finalement
fait demi-tour et décidé de lancer de
nouvelles centrales il était trop tard
alors c'est vrai que DF a commis des
erreurs EDF a pris des retards notamment
sur la construction de centrale de
nouvelle génération mais objectivement
c'est la sphère politique ce n'est pas
propre à laquelle président de la
République mais ça fait plus de deux
décennies que la France a fait ce choix
implicite de démanteler sa filière
nucléaire qui était en des secteurs une
des d'excellence de notre pays et on en
paye aujourd'hui un prix absolument
exorbitant c'est d'autant plus choquant
que cette filière avait été construite
avec l'argent des Français et avec
l'argent du contribuable quel serait
donc la solution faut-il relancer en
France le programme nucléaire c'est en
effet ce que souhaite aujourd'hui le
gouvernement si nous
voulons avoir
une objective climatique et continuer à
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il faut remplacer les énergies
fossiles par des énergies bas carbone
l'électricité produite en France et
aujourd'hui bas carbone et le nucléaire
est aujourd'hui l'énergie la plus bas
carbone de toutes les solutions dont
nous disposons malgré cette volonté la
France pourra-t-elle échapper aux
coupures d'électricité cet hiver le
problème c'est qu'il est trop tard un
chef d'État c'est quelqu'un qui doit
avoir loin c'est ce que faisait le
général de Gaulle quand il a lancé cette
politique de production nucléaire et
aujourd'hui il est un peu tard pour
pleurer